so let's ask ourselves some interesting
questions about alphabets in the English
language and in case you don't remember
and the mood to count there are 26
alphabets so if you go a b c d e f g h
ng canna pqrstuvwxyz you get you get 26
26 alphabets now let's ask some
interesting questions so given that
there are 26 alphabets in the English
language how many possible three-letter
words are there and and we're not gonna
be thinking about phonetics for how hard
it is to pronounce it so for example the
word the herd ziget would be a
legitimate word this example or the word
the word the word sched would be a
legitimate work if it's example so how
many possible three-letter words are
there in the English language encourage
you to pause the video and try to think
about it alright I assume you had a go
at it
so let's just think about it for three
letter words there's three spaces so how
many possibilities are there for the
first one
well there's 26 possible letters for the
first one
anything from A to Z would be completely
fine now how many possibilities for the
second one and I intentionally asked
this to you to be a distractor because
you might be you know we've seen a lot
of examples we're saying oh there's 26
possibilities for the first one and then
maybe there's 25 for the second one and
then 24 for the third but that's not the
case right over here because we can
repeat letters I didn't say that all the
letters had to be different so for
example the word the word would also be
a legitimate word in our example right
over here so we have 26 possibilities
for the second letter and we have 26
possibilities for the third letter so
we're going to have and I don't know
what this is 26 to the third power
possibilities or 26 times 26 times 26
and you could figure out what that is
that is how many possible three-letter
words we can have for the English
language if we didn't care about how
pronounceable they are if they meant
anything and if we repeated letters now
let's ask a different question what if
we said how many possible three-letter
words
are there if we want all different
letters so we want all different letters
so these all have to be different
letters different different letters and
once again pause the video and see if
you can think it through
alright so this is where permutations
start to be useful although I you know I
think a lot of things like this it's
always best to reason through than to
try to figure out whether some formula
applies to it so in this situation well
if we went an order we could have 26
different letters for the first one 26
different possibilities for the first
one you know I'm always starting with
that one but I there's nothing special
about the one on the left we could say
that the one on the right there's 26
possibilities well for each of those
possibilities for each of those 26
possibilities there might be twenty-five
possibilities for what we put in the
middle one if we say we're gonna figure
out the middle one next and then for
each of these 25 times 26 possibilities
for where we figured out two of the
letters there's 24 possibilities because
we've already used two letters for the
last bucket that we haven't filled and
the only reason why I went where I went
26 25 24 is to show you there's nothing
special about always filling in the what
the leftmost letter or the leftmost
chair first it's just about well let's
just think in terms of let's fill out
one of the buckets first hey we have the
most possibilities for that once we use
something up then for each of those
possibilities we'll have one left one
less for the the the next the next
bucket and so I could do 24 times 25
times 26 but just so I don't fully
confuse you I'll go back to the what I
have been doing 26 possibilities for the
leftmost one for each of those you would
have 25 possibilities for the next one
that you're going to try to figure out
because you've already used one letter
and they have to be different and then
for the last bucket you're gonna have 24
possibilities so this is going to be 26
times 25 times 24 whatever that happens
to be and if we wanted to write it in
the notation of permutations we would
say that this is equal to we're taking
26 things signed up to P 20 my brain is
malfunctioning 26 we're taking on how
many permutations are there for putting
26 different things into three different
space
and this is 26 if we just blindly apply
the formula which I never suggest doing
it be 26 electorial over 26 minus three
factorial which would be 26 factorial
over 23 factorial which is going to be
exactly this right over here because the
23 times 22 times 21 all the way down to
one is going to cancel with the 23
factorial and and so the whole point of
this video there's two points is one you
know what as soon as someone says hello
how many different letters could you
form or something like that you just
don't blindly do permutations or
combinations you think about well what
is being asked in the question here I
really just have to take 26 times 26 26
the other thing I want to point out I
know I keep pointing it out and it's
probably getting tiring to you is even
when permutations are applicable in my
brain at least it's always more valuable
to just try to reason through the
problem as opposed to just saying oh my
there's this formula that I remember
from weeks or years ago in my life that
had n factorial and K factorial and have
to memorize and have to look it up
always much more useful to just reason
it through